the Transformers movies live action
Transformers movies anyway well they're
Transformers movies and there was a
contrast there but now the maximals have
entered the fight and the words of the
great Count Dooku I've been looking
forward to this
[Music]
so Transformers rise of the Beast is
directed by Stephen cable Jr that's
right no longer directed by Michael Bay
well bumblebee wasn't either but the
point is new directories fresh new ideas
it's not Optimus Prime in the Autobots
Optimus primal and the maximals they
gotta team up try to stop bad things
from happening basically trying to get
the thing before the big bads get the
thing and trying to keep it vague
because big bad was alluded to in the
trailer but not really set it's not like
they're like hey unicorn
is coming
oh I guess I did say it in the trailer
okey-doke well Transformers the last
Knight's been retconned and now you know
that a moment of silence for lost
garbage and this movie starts out pretty
great awesome setup with Optimus Prime
all I was ready I was in and then a
human characters
still not directed by Michael Bay we'll
see where it goes but this movie does
have the human element concentrating on
human beings so the audience can have
that human element to latch onto which
we never really needed in the animations
both Transformers and Beast Wars alike
granted the original Transformers series
as well as the animated movie they had
humans in it but it never revolved
around them in the way that the
Transformers live action movies have but
I will say rise to the base as well as
Bumblebee have done that human element a
lot better than the Transformers movies
that came before it live action that is
keep saying that because the animated
movie is absolutely amazing any movie
that has an action sequence to weird
Alice dare to be stupid it's amazing in
my book but it's Noah Diaz and Dominique
fish back this time around mainly
concentrates around Noah Diaz I thought
he did a great job it was a relatable
dude who's just thrown into the mix of
this situation he actually has solid
comedic timing bouncing off of Pete
Davidson who plays Mirage who plays the
voice of Mirage in here however I will
say either the script is self-aware or
is Pete Dave Davidson ad-libbing when
the script gets a little too cheesy
there's one line in particular where he
just kind of makes a joke about it
sounding cheesy when it left his mouth
that's either in the script or Pete
Davidson was like I'm I'm making a joke
about this because the only way it works
speaking of great energy that's also the
soundtrack this movie takes place
canonically a few years after the
Bumblebee movie so now we're in the
early 90s and the soundtrack they have
something about a soundtrack it's just
it's how you know where you are in
history the entire movie of Forrest Gump
you knew which decade we were in because
of the music that played right so you
have yourself some nice early 90s
soundtrack going on in here I thought it
was great not a playlist no a mixtape
called that a mixtape the robot fights I
thought were fun you know the robot
versus robot fights they should be
entertaining they should be they should
be spectacle I felt I did a good job
with that however I felt they did a good
job with that when they were fighting
near a museum or recognizable terrain
because the last Act of this movie when
you had all the robots fighting this was
some plain gray molten [__] like a
less interesting version of Mordor
complete with a whole tower that looks
like barador it's weird and now that
we're talking about the last act I gotta
say there were so many conveniences and
mcguffins in this script for the last
act it was just ridiculous I mean
granted the whole movie revolves around
everyone looking for a thing which is
always a thing Transformers movies has
just gotta have a thing at that point
it's the Amazing Race to find the thing
first right absolutely but in the last
act when it was like oh this is a
problem okay well we'll do this this and
this and then you can get into the thing
and do this thing that requires is a
very conveniently human-sized problem so
we can have the humans do something
while we're all fighting so they don't
feel useless you know for the sake of
the movie The Audience was laughing
granted there were jokes in the movie in
which the audience was laughing with the
movie but in the last act when they were
spelling out all of these conveniences I
felt like the audience was turning on
the movie and they were laughing at the
movie felt like someone wrote the script
and fell asleep on the keyboard and
someone's kid just came in and was like
and I want to put these in here I think
that really polishes it up well okay I'm
late for kindergarten hope it works out
then that script was just turned in
without any proofreading no one
questioned it at all luckily for this
movie it's like it was recognized it was
like okay
among all these conveniences and this
boring landscape or having this last
final Throwdown happen at we need a
couple of badass moments to really stick
The Landing here if the audience is
going nuts
none of the rest of it matters not in
the moment anyway undeniably there were
a couple of badass moments you couldn't
help but smile the biggest
disappointment is with the maximals
entirely it's called rise of the beasts
not really it's not really them rising
at all you get the biggest Arc with
Optimus primal I was glad to see that
but really generally the rest of his
troops you don't really know much about
them Michelle yo is air razor has the
most dialogue but chidor has less rhinox
does he even talk like he was there to
be a big brute smashed baddies for the
final acts they didn't really feel like
characters at all granted it's a very
packed film you have the baddies causing
problems you have the humans the movie
revolves around then you have the
Autobots the maximals right so there's
going to be some folks are going to get
left on the sidelines I thought
concentrating on Optimus primal for the
maximals that was a smart move but as a
beast wars fan I wanted to see more hell
I want to see just a beast wars
Standalone film I feel like that could
still happen one of the more interesting
arcs in the movie is Optimus Prime times
are because Optimus Primes I've always
seen him as you know he's he's robot
Jesus right he's he's that good and he's
always been that good and freedom is the
right of all sentient beings we know the
phrases is like Gandalf the light
cosplay as a robot and he's Optimus
Prime so I like to see Optimus Prime be
this Wise Old Sage of a battle-hardened
space deity in this movie he's like you
brought a human here who brought the
trash he's kind of a dick to human
beings at first he doesn't like him but
there is that Arc of growth with him
showing yes you can have the Autobots be
characters in and of themselves and you
don't need the movie to revolve around
human beings in order to make it work
but in the end I enjoyed Transformers
rise of the Beast for Transformers
movies with the live-action Transformers
movies anyway a franchise that has a
contrast that ranges between yeah I
enjoyed that but it has problems to how
the [__] did that movie get made this
was one of the enjoyable ones that does
have problems but it is one of the
better live action Transformers movies
and it does leave you off with that
feeling of I'm interested and I want to
see where they go with this unless I had
me a fun time no alcohol required
there's a Transformers rise of the Beast
have you seen it what did you think
about her should want to rank the
Transformers movies
it's a tall order or you can be like
ranking them aside I like these ones I
don't like these ones leave it at that
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]